[Music]  I really love moles because they're  extremely versatile not only can you  make different treats in them but one  molds like one shape can be used to make  a bunch of different themed things this  is a treat mold that looks like little  swirls or poops looks like little 3d  poops you can make treats to look like  the top of an ice cream or you can  decorate them to look like my favorite  emoji the poop emoji something that  people may not be aware of as a lot of  the items have a lot of versatility not  only can you bacon them but you can also  use them for crafting and there's a  bunch of items in the line for beginner  bakers  [Music]  one of the things I love about cooking  and baking is that it is a life skill  you can also express yourself you can  find me on social media at Rosanna  pansino on everything  [Music]